richard vallières c'est un homme qui a
été condamné à huit ans de prison pour
avoir volé pour à peu près 10 millions
de dollars de sirop d'érable dans
l'ensemble du québec il devra finalement
payer une amende équivalant au montant
du vol la cour suprême a confirmé
aujourd'hui la peine initiale qui avait
été infligée en 2016 cette peine il
avait été renversé par la cour d'appel
alors pour discuter de cette amende
vraiment importantes ont joint l'avocat
criminaliste marc labelle bonjour m
label
la cour suprême établi le montant de
l'amendé en fonction de la valeur de la
marchandise mais en fait c'est la cour
de première instance mais là c'est
validé par la cour suprême c'est ce que
c'est toujours comme ça on voit combien
le combien on ne vole y est ça équivaut
à l'amande
que la mangue compensatoires ce dont il
est question c'est un espèce doute 6 211
qui vit tout seul dans le sens où ça
fait partie de la peine mais ça a une
vie complètement indépendant ce que le
juge doit décider si désir d'imposer une
amende compensatoire
c'est de quelle est la valeur que kelly
le profit que le criminel a tiré de ses
activités
et là il divo pour
une évaluation de ce que ça représente
et sur celle amende compensatoire
scapo suprême a décidé aujourd'hui c'est
que c'est la valeur
dans le cas qui nous occupe par exemple
c'était le 1100 quelques ben ali de
sierocki vers les 18 millions monsieur
vallières avait admis qu'ils en avaient
eu et il y avait des transactions pour à
peu près 10 millions mais que au bout de
la ligne c'est y avait rapporté un
profit de 1 million alors la cause le
juge de première instance dit très bien
moi je considère que la marque
compensatoires l'avait fait un profit de
vos activités criminelles de 10 millions
c'est dix millions c'est comme si 10
millions la cour d'appel avait dit non
c'est le profit alors le profit c'est un
million conséquemment c'est un million
et loeb un la concerne il est habile
on comprend que si ils sont obligés de
lui infliger une amende de 10 millions
ça veut dire qu'ils ont pas retrouvé du
million n'a pas pu saisir l'équivalent
de 10 millions dans ses comptes de
banque par exemple un amant
compensatoires c'est quand on peut pas
confisquer les biens alors les produits
de la criminalité
s'ils peuvent être confisqués c'est cela
qu'on commence par les complicités si on
peut parler confié belle à celle amende
compensatoire
je colle à la seule discrétion que le
juge or c est ce que j'en ai pas aux
jeunes ou pas il peut décider qui
constate que des profits mais il impose
pas d'amande compensatoire mais juge
possible décide qu'il impose c'est la
balle en vue du profit qui peut faire
peur alors ici les combien d'argent
contrôler l'accusé a effectué la visite
ici quand même la cour et réaliste 10
millions c'est un montant considérable
on se comprend il doit la cour d'un 10
ans arrivant vallières pour rembourser
ou pour payer cette amende là mais
comment ça fonctionne on appelle le
percepteur des amendes et on lui dit je
vais faire un virement de 10 millions
non c'est pas tout à fait comme ça que
ça fonctionne en fait monsieur vallières
il ya dix ans il peut faire ce qu'il
veut
il peut en payer une partie et il peut
payer temps en temps il peut il fait ce
qu'il veut de dix ans pour payer
cependant si pep au moins qui est prévu
par la cour suprême c'est une peine de
six ans d'emprisonnement à être purgée
consécutivement tout autre repère alors
on connaît le système des libérations
conditionnelles
normalement au tiers de la peine on peut
être remise en liberté est-ce que vous m
label vous avez déjà eu des clients qui
vous ont dit bof je veux aller la purger
ma peine de prison puis tant pis pour la
membres parce que quand mes dix millions
de valeur à moins qu'il ait vraiment une
fortune planqué quelque part
les clients
c'est de payer parce que les laits
période d'emprisonnement défaut quand
cédé à défaut de paiement cds sont
importants c'est un pensez y bien par
contre l'oscal en jeu c'est le
percepteur des amendes au bout de dix
ans si on a pas on n'est pas capable de
rencontrer ses obligations paiement
je regardais seule aujourd'hui est le
programme de travaux compensatoires
serait applicable un cas comme celui de
monsieur vallières à mon avis et le
maximum tu pourrais faire c'est toi 120
heures de travaux bon alors je pense
qu'on va ça qu'on va s'en reparler dans
dix ans mais on va assurément suivre ce
dossier là merci beaucoup marc labelle
de nous en avoir parlé
bienvenue au revoir